and the Oscar goes to interstellar
jungle Blade Runner 2014 our first man
here are this year's nominees for
achievement and visual effective best
way to start I think is just by you
telling me you are what you do okay well
my name is Niko pairing er I'm one of
the founders of corridor digital which
is a YouTube channel and we specialized
in doing VFX action-heavy spectacle
heavy YouTube videos OH
so we're here today to talk about the
movies that were nominated for an Oscar
for visual effects the whole thing with
this movie is that it's made to look
like it was done in one take there's a
lot entirely revolutionary and you know
unexplored before but they're doing more
complicated setups and scenes while
still trying to maintain that one take
look the challenge they have with that
is that these effects need to be
invisible I would love to talk about
this long run scene if you look at the
behind the scenes shot and then the
actual shot from the film you know first
thing you might notice is like oh
there's some extra explosions added or
there's some extra soldiers but what you
might not notice is it's things like the
tire tracks from the car that they're
driving had been removed or the dust
being kicked up from the tires and
that's much much more complicated than
just adding another explosion in the
background the challenge of 1917 is
doing these invisible effects but doing
them for long takes and then having
these hidden cuts be seamless because
the moment you you get one of those
little details wrong you break the world
so I think looking at the scene well
would probably surprise most people
looking at it is that the vast majority
of it is 100% CG stormtroopers the
speeders ass and all that kind of stuff
there's a phrase for things like the
dust clouds and the physics and things
like that the smoke you know it's
usually referred to as dynamics that's
when the first like very first giveaways
as the CG scene is looking at the smoke
and it being pass almost like painterly
quality or it's not quite realistic
and we're just kind of getting to the
point where we can kind of match real
life with that
[Music]
I think a lot of the hype that I heard
was definitely around these animals but
you were talking about how it's really
the setting that impressed you I'd say
the biggest thing that stands out to me
in any of these environment shots is the
vast number of actual objects on screen
you know like this the shot of Mufasa
and Simba walking through the grass as
we focus away from the spider and onto
them there's thousands of blades of
grass in the scene there's leaves
there's hundreds of leaves on the bush
and from the camera and so all of these
things need to have this incredible
amount of detail that's what stands out
to me as being incredible here you know
yeah the animation is great the
rendering impeccable you know the
lighting simulation great wonderful you
know all that's awesome but the fact
that all that comes together cohesively
that's why crazier to me so actually
there's a couple things about Avengers
that that are really impressive one of
the first ones is the the time-travel
suits all those suits that you see them
ring those are completely CG and they
look completely realistic you cannot
tell them they're a they replace the
entire body except for the head and
that's insane why would they do that
well it takes a lot of time to construct
these costumes for these characters and
it's only thing used for five minutes of
the film is there anything like
particular on the suits that made them
stand out to you so I was scrutinizing
the suits and I watched the scene again
and the only things that really give
them away as being CG and you have to
really be looking for it and what you're
looking for it's when they're
interacting with someone something real
so a suit really only interacts with two
real things the neckline of the actor
and the feet on the ground you have to
fake the shadow from this you know the
suit Dean cast in the ground and there's
a lot of nuances to that but nobody's
analyzing the neck lines you know to me
out of all the films I've been nominated
for you know an Oscar here for Best
Visual Effects the Irishman has the most
unique brand-new technology
so so the reason they're going through
all this trouble is because they want to
tell a story of a character throughout
his entire life and they need to get him
at his you know when he was 60 when he
was 50 when he was 40 when he is 30 how
do we let this guy shoot the movie like
this with actors not wearing any markers
or tracking suits and yet we somehow
need to
sure a pole 3d model of the face for
every frame of the movie basically the
whole real-time 3d motion capture they
just lit the scene with infrared lights
from the the witness cameras they're
called so they're seeing the scene with
perfect lighting and we can't see with
our eyeballs the actors can't see the
infrared light the main camera that
they're filming the scene let's can't
see the infrared light and is really
really smart they did encounter one
problem and that is old cars old car
windshields in class II used to use lead
when they'd make the glass LED doesn't
let infrared light through so they
actually had to remove all the
windshields from the cars and anytime
that see a car in the film that
windshield the reflection of the
windshield that's fake do people really
care about this award you know these are
just five films and a good chunk Lamarr
just kind of doing the same techniques
we've already done in fact when it comes
to visuals there's so much going on in
the space every year you're building off
the knowledge and the tools that you've
gained from the previous year so these
these more advanced techniques that
they're using for all these movies you
know it's it's letting the visuals -
looking a lot more photo real but we've
seen it before the Oscars it's good
recognition but there's so much more
that drives an artist at least a visual
effects artist outside hoping to win an
award like an Oscar
you
[Music]